welcome back to on base live we are back
in beautiful Seattle
with uh
JP Crawford
thanks for coming on brother thanks for
having me man hey man it's some
beautiful weather this is the first time
I've really been in Seattle and it's
beautiful like this usually you know
it's kind of rainy a little bit or it's
cold or whatever it's like this a lot
during the summertime uh summertime yeah
man you can't beat it uh it gets dark at
like 10 o'clock bro oh really easy it's
nice yeah so so what is there to do here
in Seattle like really because I I've
never really I've never I mean other
than the All-Star Game I got to walk
around a little bit but did you go to
Pike's Place I mean I've been there once
and I've seen them throw the fish me and
the wife we went walk seen them throw
the fish but outside of that I don't
know what else there there is to really
do man well I'm all the way in The
Boondocks I live in Woodinville that's
like 30 minutes north in the middle of
nowhere so I don't really do much
um
but if you want to go downtown
place I think that's it that's all just
Pike's Place all right well I know
there's some good restaurants here so
anyways
you want a gold glove before and you won
the uh the heart and hustle this year
heart and hustle award this year what
what does that mean I I don't even know
what the heart and hustle I mean I know
it's an award but what what is it that
you did to win and just you know leading
my team I think just play hard every day
and you know just play every game like
it's your last and you know have that
energy every day and I think that's why
I want it is that kind of uh
bug your motto like that that's kind of
how you play by it's like leading your
team with energy leading with being
obviously by example and those type of
things it's kind of like uh you're
you're Mo yeah for sure I'm not gonna be
that rah-rah guy but you know I'm gonna
lead how how I play how I hustle and
yeah lead by that because I'm not gonna
go chew you out for something right
um we're all trying right exactly we all
get it and so yeah just lead by example
and just play hard and you know the rest
will take care of itself and that's how
you win a hard and hustle Awards I I
don't know if I've ever won one I want
to win one I don't know what I'll do
differently but we'll see that's crazy
so before we get all in into the show uh
you know we we play a game called on
base off base
and I want to hear from you
you know what on base office is right
you need to re-enlighten me please so
it's whether you're inner in or out like
you're in on this you're out on it right
all right on base off base so
team
fantasy football leagues
on base tell me are you in a league or
I'm in a couple I got four four leagues
the Mariners have a league yeah we have
a league here and then I got a family
league with my wife and her family and I
got two friend leagues so
which which League do you feel like you
have the best team
I would say my team League here with the
Mariners okay so so
who uh who who was your first overall
pick I went Tony Pollard and then
Patrick Mahomes I think it messed
everyone's draft order yeah I think I
think so I took my homes and uh I had
the 12th pick then we did a little snake
draft so I took him back to back and I
think it threw everyone off
um have you won in the first first
couple weeks yeah I mean there's only
been one game so far and that's the only
League I won Oh I thought
okay so how what's y'all's buy-in for
the league three G's three nice so I
mean that's the only thing I'm really
caring about at this point all right all
right so what about this on base off
base having an entire rack dedicated for
the opposing team when they come into
play against you guys
entire rack entire rack of clothes I'm
sorry in the uh
the players and the uh the team store oh
I'm sorry the team store not off base
you're off why are you off based on that
bro
this is our Stadium why do you want
someone else's gear at our Stadium
because what if somebody from La moved
to Seattle well get your stuff from LA
and then bring it with you now this is
our place
again it does it doesn't grow you don't
think it helps grow the game or anything
it might but you ain't worried about it
I ain't worried about that don't worry
about our fans having our clothes not
our opposing teams that we're playing
okay so JP is off base uh guys you will
not see my jersey today at uh T-Mobile
stadium so okay what about on base off
base
aliens are real
onbase no come on oh yeah okay tell me
your theory let's hear I'm a bit
conspiracist like that okay so let's
hear why your conspiracy theory on why
you believe aliens are real
foreign
just a tiny Speck in the big universe
there's no way we're the only thing out
here it's like taking a spoon taking it
in the ocean looking at the spoon with
the water in it being like Oh there's no
fish in here
aliens are real man
okay so have you seen
like what have you seen
that will make you say that I got a
story from out here
um I think it was in 21 we're living on
Mercer Island right here and one night
my wife had some of her friends over too
so I got witnesses on this okay
we're outside I was grilling out and
then like the corner what were you
cooking on the grill steaks steaks okay
phenomenal okay
um and then we're seeing this thing it's
like a disc but there's no lights in it
whatever a disc but no lights it's like
uh yeah like you're looking in the sky
looking in the sky and like all of a
sudden a couple seconds later it's
already like above us almost and we're
like
oh shoot
like babe go grab your camera this ain't
this ain't a plane and then so she
grabbed her like camera camera it
wouldn't focus on it nothing it wouldn't
focus on what I'm gonna focus on it but
you could see it but you could see it
clearer like clear
and then all of a sudden it was gone
like 30 seconds later just
gone and then I followed this alien page
on Instagram
same thing they said we visited last
night by this UFO same like how it
looked it was the same I went crazy let
me tell you so
are you sure it just wasn't a regular
plane or nothing no it was too far up
there and there were no like blinking
lights or nothing
no wings no nothing
it wasn't a shooting star enough nope
you see some stuff up here let me tell
you
so in Seattle this is this is
this is where aliens are in Seattle I
want to say where they are but I mean
where I live it's so dark you can see
this guy and we go like look at the
stars all the time at night and you
could just see some stuff
do you know like where the Big Dipper
and all that stuff is too you know
Ryan's version yeah
I don't know what none of that is okay
so
um what about this on base off base it's
rude to order a frappuccino Chino in the
morning
off base
I mean why would it be rude I don't know
if people like a frappuccino
isn't the Frappuccino with all the uh
uh whipped cream and stuff on top
I couldn't tell you I don't know I don't
know I thought you were a coffee guy
because you know we're in Seattle and
you know Starbucks and all that stuff
yeah I just get a cold brew I don't know
you see you're a cold guy cold brew guy
what what's your so you go to Starbucks
do you go on the road too yeah so you
you got a card and everything you
probably got the app and everything a
nice gift card from them yeah you got to
happen so so because Freddy Freddy is
like that he he got the app on his phone
and those are all the Starbucks
okay so all right so when you go and you
order
what's your order well it's pumpkin
spice pumpkin spice season now so I'm
getting a pumpkin cold brew but if it's
not this season I'm getting a sweet
cream cold brew sweet cream cold brew
like two shots of espresso in there
and now that it's getting the fall time
you go the pumpkin spice and then is
there one in the winter time is there
like a uh not just the pumpkin one still
pumpkin spice
have you had that before no I don't
drink coffee I don't drink caffeine
actually
so my my theory is
if I can't wake up
to play a big league game
then
there's something wrong with you
now this is not for everyone this is
just for me I feel you you know what I'm
saying
there I am yawning and sleepy a lot
during the game but when I you know when
we get on the field you wake up you know
and whatnot but I'll tell you I'm a big
Napper I take naps all the time
so uh
if not but if I don't get an app or
I just Thug it you know I just I just
stuck it I think it'll just help the
cause a little bit I think it would too
I truly think it would too
I don't know maybe we'll see we'll see
just keep doing what you're doing yeah
all right so get in the ball now uh
services that you're kind of like the QB
of the Mariners right and so what does
that mean to you
um I mean just like I'm the captain of
the infield I'm the captain on the field
I feel like um everyone looks to me and
you know I take that I don't take that
for granted yeah so how does that make
you feel like because not that long ago
we kind of came around the same time I
was a little bit before you
but
not that long ago we were you were the
young guy and now you're the QB so like
how does that make you feel it makes me
feel it makes me feel special man
um honored to be honest because you know
they trust me in handling everything and
I think that means a lot nice okay so if
you're the QB right
who is your
uh number one wide receiver
man
well God gotta say Julio you got like a
mini DK right yeah
okay who is uh who's your running back
okay I gotta go JK man I gotta go Kelly
Nick right here you know fast yep
biggest yeah big he'll run he'll he'll
look like he'll run through somebody
exactly okay so you got Julio
JK Kelly Nick Mr Kelly okay so who who
would be
your D end at the end the end yeah
Maybe demagogino
Gino
sneaky right there I can see him getting
into some Havoc right there okay so this
is the most important position
arguably
who's your kicker
dang
that could have been Gino because Gino's
got a boot he gone though I know he gone
sorry Gino
um
I've only seen him kick a football
but all right all right we're gonna go
with kick her and it's gotta be someone
you rely on that you know when it's
crunch time because there's two seconds
left I need you to kick this field goal
through here
I'm gonna go tail
let's go and tell
he's just he's gonna do it
okay so get this year bro a little bit
about this year you've uh increased your
power you know you're driving the ball a
little more
um how have you how have you feel like
you've done that and how via first will
say how have you feel like you've done
that like what what mechanical changes
or mindset was it that that has helped
you
um I think it was just all the training
I did in the off season
um I went down the Driveline and you
know finally had a plan yep and working
and you know just actually working on
increasing bad speed and just having a
plan going into the off season knowing
about just how to get better I think
really helped me this year and you know
when you start hitting for power and you
know hitting stop hitting ground balls
and hitting doubles now you know
confidence goes up and you know every
day you're like okay I'm gonna I'm Gonna
Get You don't matter who's on there now
once that once you get that confidence
like
I know I'm gonna get you it's just a
matter of when and not a matter of if
that's a good feeling it's great it's a
that's a that's a great that's a great
feeling so
are there any outside of just you know
the bat speed training because that's
not really like a mechanical thing like
are there any mechanical things that you
that you have done that you mind sharing
that you you don't have to share if you
don't want to
um I think just for me I lowered my
hands a little bit and it may be shorter
to the ball yeah
um
I was putting myself in a bad spot to
fire from earlier like with my lower
half too and you know I just wanted to
get more in the ground and stay there
you know stop leaking out in front and
yeah so
these things have haven't had they been
hard to
manage throughout the season because you
know you've done a bad speed training
because I'm asking because for me it
I've done the best speed training with
Driveline as well and sometimes it just
gets hard to manage because it's a
different routine and this is kind of my
first year doing a different routine
granted it's yeah it's worked right but
it's kind of hard to remember all the
things and
change your time you know change what
you're doing in this in the uh great
room and all those type of things and so
how has it been managing all those new
things
um it's been good you know I just took a
couple of key things that really helped
me and helped my swing like with my load
and some of the drills I took the I do
like two or three every day
um some days if I'm feeling really like
sluggish or slow I'll pick up the weight
training bags or you just get some
caffeine
no I have caffeine every day
that's not the issue right there
and yeah you know um the routine pretty
much has stayed the same okay so a lot
has been good good good so you guys are
and as I talked to Julio yesterday you
guys are right on the postseason the
brink of postseason how is it how is it
playing uh
you know for postseason spot every year
like
this gotta be fun right I mean
especially being here it was packed it
was packed yesterday and the other times
I've been it hasn't been that packed you
know and so it seems fun and I want to
hear from you yeah you know these games
mean everything they're so fun and this
is what baseball is all about man the
sold out crowds and just every pitch
matters you know there's no better
baseball than that so if you don't find
a join that you know you're in the wrong
Sport and then you guys played a
y'all play a long game what last year or
a couple years ago a long postseason
game I want to say this was in we've
both been yeah 18 inning games I'm sorry
how long was your was yours do you
remember oh yeah I think I was at ours
was 18 too how long was the game do you
remember probably like five hours
something like that
let's look at my handy dandy notebook
okay y'all's with six hours after a six
hour game
what did you do
I think I just sat in my locker for a
little bit that's all you can do right
that's all you can do I remember playing
we had we played a seven hour game in
2018 against the Dodgers in the World
Series and yeah you just sit there sit
there you're mad you know honestly I'd
have had a beer and you know just tried
to calm down a little bit
did your caffeine wear off after 18
Innings yeah it did so what did you what
did you what did you use for your source
of energy at that point or were you just
like you know what I'm just tired it is
what it is not Red Bull oh sugar-free
though had to keep it going
throttling
mom didn't raise no quitter at all all
right so
at what point this season though
I mean I guess you know in the last
couple years really but this use this
season especially did you realize all
right this team we got a really good
ball club we really can make this happen
um you know because obviously you go
into spring training and everybody says
says like oh no we're good we're good
we're here to win we're here to win but
not every team every team knows like
okay we're we really can you know we're
not
ready yet or whatever it is right at
what point this year did you know like
nah this is we're we're really good and
we can really make a run at this
um I would say in the beginning man um
it was just we were losing games but it
was just that one hit that you know we
didn't get that one clutch hit and
we were losing a bunch of games but it
was just a matter of when we're gonna
just come out of this and break out and
in the summer we finally had that we got
a little streak going and that's when I
knew like okay yeah we got a chance here
let's go you guys seem like really
close-knit too like do you guys like get
to hang out much off the field or do
things at the hotel play video games
what is it that you got because you guys
have seen from the outside looking in it
seems like you guys are pretty close
yeah man we have a good time I think we
have one of the best clubhouses around
we have so much fun um
I don't know man we just got the Good
Vibes we hang out at the field
um we'll go get dinner especially
especially we have an off day we're
going to grab dinner for sure
um yeah all those times yeah just find
little ways to hang out yeah exactly
typical stuff all right so let's get
into let's get into JP you're from La
where are you from in L.A born in Long
Beach and then once I was like eight or
nine moved to Lakewood which is right
around the corner so and you played
travel ball what other sports did you
play I played basketball growing up too
and then once I got the high school just
focused on baseball why why did you what
you didn't want to hoop no more and the
school I was going to they weren't
really that good at Hoops it was more
for baseball and you know I thought why
just waste my time losing every game
instead of just getting ready getting
better at baseball so okay so you played
you didn't never play football or
anything no man my dad wouldn't let me
play pop warner or anything growing up
and uh he played professional too can he
go yeah yeah he he man he knew he knew
yeah yeah he knew okay so so you playing
ball get into high school and when did
you start getting noticed by the scouts
probably say like my sophomore junior
year
um my baseball team was pretty good we
had a first rounder my best friend a
year before me so you know we always had
scouts at our games and whatnot so I
would say around then and did they make
you nervous when they came yeah I
remember I remember hitting BP and them
being right there watching and I'm like
man you know you feel like you can't
mess up and all that all those type of
feelings and you're in high school
that's that's kind of hard to hard to
deal with but we uh we did just fine
with this so
you you're balling ball and ball and
then you get drafted right go to the
Phillies
how did you feel when you got drafted
tell me about the day you got dropped
and it was Unforgettable I was in New
York my family came with me and some of
my friends and
just hearing my name
um kind of just sit there I sort of
stood there like okay like anything this
is real right now and then put on the
jersey and
you know life changed after that real
quick did uh did y'all go to dinner
right afterwards
to be honest I don't remember what we
did what did you what did you buy the
first thing you bought I bought a car
down when I was in Florida what kind of
car a Camaro just the regular V6 one
though
and
no jewelry or anything after that just
the car just the car did you get your
folks anything
no nothing okay I'm a hug
that works too okay so you're going
through the minor leagues with the
Phillies
and you debuted with the Phillies right
yes
that's a tough Market to be in
can you tell me the difference between
just the markets in between like I've
been somewhere like Philly and then
being somewhere like Seattle
um it's a lot more laid back here
um
I think the the fans over there they
care a lot you know they're passionate
about everything but you know if you
don't do your job they're going to let
you know about it for sure so yeah it
was hard
and so
being there
how how and and you were a top prospect
coming up
and you're in Philly now that you said
like they're gonna let you know right so
there's a lot of high expectations for
you how do you how do you feel like
that played a part in your time in
Philly
um yeah like every at-bat I was trying
to get three hits in one of that you
know because you're the top guy you have
to do everything at all times and uh
locked in any turn my way or didn't go
my way you know any kind of snowballs
after that too because like you get that
negative that negative
thing that didn't have that didn't go
your way and then another one happens
and then it just gets more and more and
now those negative thoughts get in your
head exactly and then you just add
injuries of that too and it's just a
yeah spiral Spiral so but then
you got a new beginning
right get traded
how was it when you got traded was it
may sound bad but whatever was it kind
of like a sigh of relief like all right
I I can go somewhere and
go be myself yeah it was the biggest uh
relief to be honest um I needed a fresh
start man and coming over here to the
West Coast it was it was big for me um
it's more my style type of baseball
um everyone's more chill like me laid
back and I get to go home oh man it was
amazing and you you
do you are you hearing I I don't I ain't
really trying to tell everybody where
your whereabouts are but do you spend
like a lot of time here do you where do
you go back to LA do you what what what
do you do how do you how do you where
you move around in off season yeah so I
mean me and my wife just bought a house
out here last year
um right after we signed our deal so
it's cold here yeah you know you don't
care no it was honestly phenomenal we
got snowed in a couple of days this
winter and that was like our first
experience with snow we ain't never seen
snow like that
so we had the time of our lives it was
awesome so
you enjoy being snowed in I enjoy it
yeah if it's a reason not to leave my
house oh I'm all for it I can't do that
okay I'm the opposite man I'm trying to
get about the house being in LA
you know the weather's beautiful I don't
have to worry about that I know I can
just get up and oh yeah go whenever I
know I want to but I guess being Snowden
is probably that's probably super cool
too especially with the wife and the new
experience it's cool yeah you know all
right so and then you your last name's
Crawford
and
there's another Crawford that you are
cousins with that you that you're family
with tell me about that like how did
y'all find out
Carl Crawford is the other one play with
the Dodgers and the Red Sox
how did uh how did y'all find out y'all
were cousins or did he did he know
before so his brother Corey reached out
to me I remember I was at Wingstop one
day and I got a text from him saying
like hey what up fam this is uh Carl
Crawford's brother Corey I'm like oh
what up and I'm like this is fam like as
in fam like a German endearment like not
actual fam you did he yeah he didn't
know at the time yeah we didn't know
okay
um
yeah and then when he was playing with
La he invited me and my family out there
and then we met and everything and but
how did you find when did you find out
these y'all were cousins
are you still don't know no no we're
definitely fam it's just like my dad
told me one day that like we're distant
cousins oh distant cousins oh you're so
like we're talking
five four five times removed or
something yeah not like oh so y'all just
that's my cousin type okay gotcha yeah
all right cool let's do it's still it's
still cool though it runs in the fam you
know what I'm saying it runs in the fan
so uh and there is I I became friends
with another guy from here
Isaiah Thomas you you cool with him yeah
when I talk about your relationship with
him well I just met him when I was
concussed I was rehabbing here and then
when the team was on the road he came in
and was rehabbing at T-Mobile too and
just started hanging out with him right
there he's super cool man he's a a super
a super good dude when I got to meet him
when I was in Boston with him and um
you know hearing his story and then
seeing all his success on the on the
field or on I'm sorry on the court
was like uh inspiring man especially
being you know his size and all that he
did and all the things that he had to go
through
um you know how has he ever talked about
any of that stuff with you no we never
really um gotten that in depth of a
conversation but you know yeah he was a
cold-blooded killer it still is you know
like you said to average all those
points that was just like his size in
the NBA their avatars out there man
they're huge and he's doing all that
exactly so tell me tell me do you have
any life
lessons
that you have learned through baseball
that you could that you have now applied
to your life
I've been wanting to ask someone this
because I can tell
you one for me
and mine is like
being able to
accept
whatever it is that comes
and move on from it so like negative
things
negative things are always coming you
know I'm saying you don't know what the
picture's throwing at you you don't know
what's about to happen
right but being able to kind of take
things accept it and move on from it and
I feel like that me when I applied that
to life because people are gonna say
stuff do stuff whatever it is
you just kind of accept people for who
they are
for sure and you move on from it so tell
me a life lesson that that you have
learned
um
I would say I learned one this year to
be honest just like life's full circle
man so it's just game you know you're
gonna have the highs you're gonna have
the lows but once you learn how to ride
them bows just ride that wave and just
don't get too high don't get too low
just kind of just ride it out and how do
you how do you how do you do that what
do you what do you do in your
your mind what how do you what do you
tell yourself in order to to do that
stay right there you know just breathe
and
just everything's like you said
everything's gonna be okay just accept
the fact that you know you're either
gonna do it or you're not right
it's only two choices there's only two
options yeah you know what I'm saying
and so in either way life is going to
continue afterwards exactly so you can
either learn from it or you know you can
go about how you want it but you give a
take a lesson out of it or let it affect
you even more so in in using that theory
or or whatever you want to call it I was
talking to Julio yesterday here and I
was kind of telling him explaining to
him like you know
him being who he is the pressures that
come along with it and you as well
and so I kind of use those theories in
life to kind of get me through the
pressures that I have being in LA and so
for you
I was telling him yesterday like he's
gonna have to play well you're gonna
have to play well especially for the
boys to win I think you know that you
know and so what is it that you do to
deal with
that pressure
outside of thinking obviously we have
the theory right but is there anything
else that you do
outside of that theory that help you
deal with that pressure because it
become it becomes a lot especially if
there's been a game or two that you
haven't played well that we may have
lost by one that you know you could have
affected you know I'm saying especially
late late now you need you need to win
you guys need to win right and so how
what is it that you uh that you do
just tell myself man just just be him
honestly um just be him I swear that
that's all I'm thinking
um keep all that negative stuff out of
there
um
and I think my teammates we we do a good
job of picking each other up and like
letting you know like hey man you got
this let's go do this like do it let's
go like someone be the someone be the
freaking hero here yep bottom of the
knife exactly someone do it and I think
uh us being true I'm
I'm not a vocal guy
you're probably more vocal vocal than I
am but I don't think you're a big vocal
guy either I don't get on the
uh the uh I'm not on the bench cheering
this to any other but I really feel like
I need to start doing that
and I feel and the reason being is
because
as one of the leaders of our team
you as well
I think some other people look to us
for support and and those because they
support us right they support us they're
they're cheering top step for us
and so
you know I really feel and I'm just
thinking about this right now like I
really feel like I should I should start
being a little more vocal cheering
cheering those guys on a little more
because
they do it for us and they're looking
for just like we look for their support
they're looking for our support you know
exactly once they hear that you know
they're like yeah yeah I think I think
we should start doing that let's do it
what do you think you're gonna hear me
tonight all right I'm gonna make sure
you give me a second tonight yeah watch
you're gonna hear me all right I'll be
looking I'm gonna be looking for you
I got to put a towel on my head because
I need to I need to cut my hair my boss
might be showing I have people taking
pictures of my balls but I can't I ain't
got time for that ain't it that's that's
not it so um anyways how how
how is it being around like Ichiro and
people like that that come across
Griffeys come around I don't even know
all other people in Seattle but like how
how is it when those people come around
do you do you learn from them and when I
first got over here
um so you know seeing him seeing Ichiro
um I was kind of StarStruck really yeah
and that guy till this day does more
than probably our whole team combined
really still does how often does he is
he out there off to he's there every day
um full uni still does his full routine
he's out there shagging and hitting in
the cage long tossing with Julio every
day like making throws a second and
stuff full routine it is incredible he
can still play right now he can still
play right now yes so he hits BP with
you guys he hits in the cage
um I'm pretty sure if he was allowed or
if he wanted to he could I would love to
see that does he throw you guys BP he
does in Spring sometimes
um he'd be throwing cheese really yeah
well I mean it's nice exactly yeah he
probably doesn't even think about it and
it just happens so he and when Griffey
comes around you get to talk to him yeah
for the show what have you what is
something that you've he's taught you
because I had him in the WBC and
hitting wise like physical wise
he didn't say a whole lot but the mind
that info that I got that's
Irreplaceable and
I can't I mean some of the stuff he was
saying I can't I mean I'm not him I
can't do the same stuff as him right but
but the way what he was thinking about
I can kind of draw I drew a parallel and
put into my own term so tell me
something that he's learned from you
um just the confidence you know I'm just
how he walks around with that all that
swag and just no one's better than me
type stuff I I think that's what I like
most about him for sure and is that why
you said tell yourself
I'm him that's why you got to tell I'm
sorry be him yeah that's what that's the
that's some where the confidence still
has to come from pretty much yeah nice
for sure so tell me tell us tell me some
more about your family too bro because I
know you're
you folks
well you say your pops played mm-hmm
in a in the CFL though right yeah the
CFL
how did you ever go to any of his games
or was that before before you were you
can remember or what was that yeah no
none of us were born oh you weren't born
yet okay okay so I never got to see any
of that do you so you don't even know if
have you watched film or anything man he
just got inducted into the Hall of Fame
right there yeah yesterday
I mean I guess that pretty much proves
this case right there yeah okay so pops
is in the Hall of Fame the Canadian
Football League Hall of Fame mom's place
who's right she played a basketball and
volleyball high school basketball and
volleyball so
but she hurt when you decided not to
play basketball anymore no no she wasn't
um I think they all knew that baseball
was the sport for me was it and you have
a sister right yeah I got two two
sisters um I got an older one she's
three years older she played softball
um she graduated from Fullerton and then
the little one she played volleyball and
she just graduated from Fullerton as
well so y'all all y'all athletes yeah
and this is you got so if if all your
immediate family is athletes and your
fifth cousin removed is a professional
professional athlete where else we got
athletes in here I mean you gotta tell
me about this yeah I mean they're
everywhere athletic family yeah so do
y'all when y'all go to family reunions
do y'all have like uh
sports like yeah go play flag football
or go hoop or something man we never
really had time to go to those because
those are always in the summer and we
were always playing and stuff and
they're all from Florida and Atlanta so
you know it was really hard for us to
get out there so not even in the off
season they won't move it around all
season my family won't either yeah I
missed every family at Union and sad
ain't it yeah and there's nothing we can
do about it though not uh you know you
know it is what it is so I want you to
tell me something about
you like something about you that people
don't know that you would like for
people to know because I this is where
this is my time to get to know people
because me and you have never really had
gotten to talk like we've known each
other
but we've never really gotten to talk
and I want to hear something about you
tell me something about JP man I'm
really easy going I don't like to leave
my house
um
I like the garden that's what people
don't really you like you you got a
green thumb I got a green thumb so okay
so tell me tell me about
your favorite thing that you've grown
shoot right now probably some banana
peppers that I got in my backyard right
now and you and you do you put them on
Pizza yeah I put them on pretty much
everything on every season them up put a
little salt and pepper on them just fry
them up a little bit eat it like that so
how often do you Garden like oh is this
all your thing even in the winter time I
guess you can't really guard in winter
time but
um yeah here the plants the or the like
vegetables and stuff will die but we
have flowers and stuff we'll put up in a
tent that we have upstairs and just keep
it up there and when it once it gets
warm again bring them back down
Gardner is your in your wife yeah she
she enjoys this she loves it do you have
any kids not yet no are you uh
how many kids you want
as many as we could get to be honest um
probably like three or four are you sure
yeah definitely mine probably like three
or four
three or four kids so do you know how
many three or four is because without
actually knowing
without actually having a kid and then
saying three or four
I think I'll be all right I'm more like
a kid myself so I think I can handle it
saying that right now with no kids
though we could check back up in a
couple of years let me know what's your
wife's name Kathy
is Kathy gonna be there tonight yes she
is I may need to holler at her and say
Hey you know JP talk about three or four
kids I want to know she talked about
three or four kids because if y'all
doing it she talking about both of y'all
doing it together I mean one three or
four together then that's one thing but
if you want three or four and she won a
couple then yeah yeah yeah we're gonna
see how we're gonna see how that go you
ever played in a Immaculate grid bro
uh the baseball thing I see him Mike
Cameron obviously his Twitter and he'll
always be doing them but I haven't you
have you've never done one uh-uh and
um I've only done it on the show and we
are
very unsuccessful on the show we've had
maybe one or two shows that we've done
decent
but we are very very unsuccessful during
the show did you see the the Red Sox
they they actually during a rain delay
put a Immaculate grid on the uh on the
scoreboard I don't know yeah it was
actually a cool book
they did it
I know
all right so Tim uh and that was during
a rain delay so what what do you do
during a rain delay what would you do
during a rain delay
um I'm just chilling you honestly you
don't sit in there play cards you don't
uh-uh
so now they're in a randomly not another
rain delay well
you just sit and wait sitting chilling
sit and chill so what if what if they
say okay well we'll know in an hour then
what are you doing
probably gonna go lay down honestly yeah
find a place to lay down for sure so
you're not a card guy or nothing
I'm not a game guy like
duh
I don't know dice or whatever no
poker
I'll play Blackjack but that's about it
so you really just be chilling big
children just chilling
chilling chilling all right so can we
put up
uh a Immaculate grid please because
we're gonna play it and based off do you
know much about base like d because I I
don't like I really don't know a whole
lot about baseball even though I play it
I don't know a whole lot and this has
taught me some things do you know a
whole lot about baseball
so that means
we'll see all right 200 plus hit seasons
and 30 30
. ain't no like clues or anything no
that's it 200 hit seasons in 30 30.
I got everybody
yeah
it's a good that's a good one I mean I
feel like Barry Bonds would be the top
three
but I don't know I don't know if you
ever had 200 hits yeah he may not have
they made it hey so we lost already oh
you what
yeah you get a certain amount of guesses
and eight on the right oh shoot 200 hit
Seasons that was 30 30.
what about the gold 200 plus 40 home
runs what about that second one
D Gordon
we can try
d
I'm going to try uh strange Gordon yeah
there you go
let's go oh point three my bad thanks
dude oh look you you cold okay it's big
bro right there 3 000 hits and had a 200
hit season I mean [__] yeah I mean
[__] for sure
we'll go with your boy
who you got Ichiro solid
oh yeah okay uh 40 Homer 3 000 hits
poolhost
definitely pool yeah solid
uh 40 Homer Gold Glove you think Griffey
ooh
might be the solid one you say you don't
know nothing about baseball but you're
answering these people like you even
think about it oh no I don't know I
don't know
oh yeah junior junior junior junior
all right uh uh I mean Gold Glove a
hernia 100 realize that could be
uh
I mean I've done that
let's do
all right let's see
I think
hello oh yeah there it is I made it
uh 100 RBIs and 3 000 hits Mickey I got
top left my bad on the 200 hits the 30
homers 30 stolen bases a cunya right
that one I don't know if he has 200 hits
but yeah does he have 200. he did
yesterday
all right a couple days ago he got it he
killing that
all right let's go
but bottom right what about uh Mickey
Cabrera right yeah uh-huh
I think we gotta go to go right there
dang
okay dang I'll mess it up
40 Homer what
a 40 30 season 40 30 40 30.
and 100 yards with 30 30.
oh no I didn't uh I'm trying to think
honey I realized with 30 30.
that's a lot that's a lot
I don't know who's doing 40 30.
rabies with that
one twice I mean I mean I I very I mean
it's got to be very bonds
right it has to be that's the only
that's the only that's the only it's a
valid guess right you know what I'm
saying we gotta send it I think let's
try it one more time
and which one the 40 the 40
for it
ah who was the top right
can we can we check can we see who to
tell
of course he's only very bonds too
hey
he never got 2008 he money I mean huh
you never get 200 hits he has 70 hold
again walk too much yeah I guess so
before we get to the fan questions
do you feel like
you are helping with the the culture of
baseball and and changing that D not not
you are helping do you feel like
we are we are we are doing our job with
it should I say
as black men
yeah
um I think so for sure
um every year me Dominic Smith we have
our little baseball Generations
foundation and we do a showcase every
November and
um just trying to give a way to give
back and we started this tournament or
the Showcase about like five six years
ago maybe and just growing over time we
get Scouts going there now and you know
we had a couple first rounders and a
bunch of people it was really good
that's really cool yeah I think so I
think we're doing our part for sure and
what about I was talking to Julio
yesterday about like celebrations in
baseball and I want to hear your take on
it I love it the game needs to grow game
needs to be fun
um you know football and basketball
they're turning up after they scoring
and stuff you know what I'm saying and I
was explaining like man this
this hard this game has gotten so hard
exactly and so we really need to
celebrate
success success yeah and it has nothing
to do with the other person yeah we're
not showing anyone up like we did our
job let us be happy about it just like
when you do your job exactly exactly
right you're striking that's how you're
going crazy why can't we do something
right yeah yeah okay so and what do you
enjoy uh when the fans because when we
do our little Freddy thing uh their
little dance thing and the fans do it I
think it's super super dope so what is
what is y'all's hit sign or or whatever
that do y'all have one
um yeah I know can Zone doesn't he do
like because the Italian thing I think
that's cool that's cool
um I do the little arrow thing after I
had to sign you in that fight man it
just fired yeah really so then we kind
of started that and then we do like a
little uh whatever you call that yeah
just a little celebration yeah all right
I really like the arrow one for sure the
arrow yeah the arrow that's yeah all
right so here here you go
you burn sage in the club in the
clubhouse tell me about that burning
stage in the clubhouse is that the bad
juju yeah just gotta get them bad vibes
out you know lose a couple games you
know you feel you just feel the energy
starting to go down you know everyone's
a little down just man get that crap out
of here and and you just take how many
how many uh
[Music]
and then you just I walk around the
whole Clubhouse with every corner
because you got to get the corners uh
the corners
you got to make sure you get the corners
and I walk around the whole thing the
kitchen batting cake especially the
batting cage uh you got to get the hits
back go in the gym training room you
know everywhere do you have any other
little
uh
is that a Superstition what is that I
want to call it a superstar
um
I don't know like a cleanse
do you have any other cleanses or
whatever you you know anything else you
do like that nah do you do your house
like that we do you do the house
so so you walk through the house and
this is if y'all argue
um nah just just guys just cause yeah
you just feel it I don't know just feel
some bad stuff so if y'all argue but if
when you're argue I don't you don't take
sage and go around it seemed like that
would be the right time yeah I'm gonna
have to try that out next time I say one
or two you know what I mean all right
all right so
next question you've played in the NL
and the AL
what's your favorite Stadium
Wrigley Wrigley Wrigley why
I'm gonna lie man one time Jay hit a
walk off Grand Slam there when I was in
Philly
I couldn't even hear myself think really
and like everything was vibrating bro it
was one of the coolest feelings I've had
on the baseball field like I know I was
on the other team yeah I was a member of
jogging off the field like damn this is
so freaking cool like this is what the
big leagues is supposed to be like it
was yeah so every time you go back to
Wrigley you feel that I do it like you
that you're gonna never forget you're
never gonna forget that I'll never
forget that yeah and
all right so what is your least favorite
I don't think I have at least face oh my
gosh nah not like for real there's only
one answer to this
what do you think Oakland see I actually
love playing at Oakland what I love
playing there I don't know the field is
good the field is great
but just the amenities and all this
stuff yeah but you know I got you can
see the ball really well there in the
box and the Enfield plays as well it's
like I think because you were in Seattle
and you have to play against them that
you have just now turned your brain to
the bright side I'm not on the bright
side exactly I'm on the negative side A
lot of people are but you know you gotta
trick your mind sometimes so you don't
have you don't have this is my least
favorite place and this has nothing to
do with the fans because it's just right
um no honestly you love going everywhere
yeah so you just love being a big leaker
then because I mean I I enjoy going
everywhere but there's some places that
it's just like I'm gonna enjoy a little
bit less you know I'm saying Oakland is
one yeah I can see that all right okay
so let's go we've got another question
would you rather
never be able to drink caffeine again oh
or never be able to eat desserts
I'm a big Sweet Tooth man I don't know
cakes pies or like cookies oh everything
so which ones no no no coffee
I'm gonna go no desserts man I don't I
don't think I'll be able to function
without caffeine to be honest yeah so it
is is is is caffeine
a drug
a good one that's a good drop yeah I
think so I mean it gets me wired for the
day so
okay so caffeine is a good drink so that
means I need to get on it then I would
say so they give me it'll get me ready
to go get you wired okay so my bad
yesterday man when I got the second year
I told you you know I didn't want to
talk to you you know it was no
disrespect yeah I know that was messed
up man I know I think when I said it I
didn't give you any context and uh I
apologize for that I apologize it's okay
you know what I'm saying um just because
I wanted to rap with you today so but
anyways bro like I ended with Julio
yesterday
um you guys are super fun to watch man
you guys are super fun to watch and uh
embrace the pressure that's coming
um
you know for these last two weeks
because you know a lot is going to
follow you Julio everybody though
everybody has a pitch well play well
play defense well all those things
but uh you know it's going to start with
you Julio a couple other guys and
it's also going to start with you being
that uh
raw raw cheerleader too watch it today
I'm on I'm looking forward to it I'm
looking forward to it so uh for those
Mariners fans that are coming to the
game tonight bring you some pom-poms
throw them over the net because JP will
need them during the game today we will
see you guys later on
later guys
[Music]